alain gautier bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
ce matin pour nous éclairer sur cette
décision la justice française a clôt
donc le dossier sur l'attentât
déclencheur du génocide au rwanda
pourquoi la france n'aura pas réussi à
aller au bout de son enquête
on savait je pense que c'était une
décision qui était complètement attendu
les complètement vite et je dirais par
le juge bruguière qui comme vous l'avez
sidaner en 2006 avait publié son rapport
qui mettait en cause des proches du
président kagame et dans
l'assassinât du président habyarimana
lorsque le juge trévidic a été nommé
hier 112 et bien les conclusions étaient
totalement différentes dont il était
tout à fait normal aujourd'hui que la
cour de cassation est bien reçue ce
pourvoi déposé dans les parties civiles
alors paul kagame on disait le président
du rwanda c'est son entourage a été visé
un temps dans cette enquête à ce qu'il y
ait eu des des réactions depuis hier au
rwanda après l'annnonce de la clôture de
ce dossier par la justice française
aurait je pense que s'il vous plaît
c'est la satisfaction générale
on a le sentiment aujourd'hui que deux
pages est enfin tourné dans ce dossier
qui a empoisonné les relations entre nos
deux pays
voilà avec nos places
de nouvelles relations mais pas sans
avoir appris que dans la sphère de la
planète contre madame habyarimana
les juges ont aussi le même jour décidé
de clôturer une information judiciaire
et
je pense là nous n'allons pas avoir de
crime nouvelle pour quelle raison parce
qu'effectivement il ya eu deux dossiers
qui ont été clos hier pour quelles
raisons dites nous
on va écouter madame madame habyarimana
et nous poursuivrons en justice depuis
le 13 février 2007
a toujours été considéré comme témoin
assisté dans cette affaire elle n'a
jamais été mise en examen or si les
juges aujourd'hui décidé de clôturer la
fédération judiciaire sans l'avoir mise
en examen il est à craindre que nous
allions vers un non lieu et ça pour nous
ce serait une décision complètement
absurde et bien évidemment nous verrons
avec nos avocats comment
continuer le mandat c'est donc la fin
d'une enquête justement de deux dossiers
mêmes qui ont empoisonné les relations
franco rwandaises pendant plus de 20 ans
est ce qu'une nouvelle page va pouvoir
réellement s'ouvrir vous venez de nous
dire qu'il restait encore d'autres
d'autres sujets de tension
oui je pense que depuis depuis la
résidence marrant les relations entre
les deux pays se sont considérablement
améliorés un nouvel ambassadeur a été
nommé ici à kigali et
après la le discours que le président
macro est venu faire
haggis aussi au mémorial de gisozi l'an
dernier auront à en reconnaissant
des
responsabilités écrasantes dans le
génocide des tutsi de la barre du
gouvernement 94
ici au moins d'annoncés satisfaits de
cette déclaration
même si nous partie civile nous aurions
bien voulu obtenir des excuses en
présence des rescapés du génocide est
ici il ya eu ce fameux rapport du clair
de l'historien du même nom sur la
question des responsabilités de la
france justement lors du génocide des
tutsi est la france portent des
responsabilités lourdes dit ce rapport
cette reconnaissance est là lui elle a
eu quelques conséquences sur les
relations entre les deux pays
on vous savez les relations aujourd'hui
sont générés sont complètement rétablis
l'ambassadeur antoine en ferait pas pris
a repris son poste ici à hacker galets
et je pense qu'il ya de la part de
gouvernements rendait la volonté
véritablement de tourner la page et de
pouvoir ainsi développer des relations
politiques économiques beaucoup plus
importante je crois que l'histoire est
en route maintenant comme on le dit
aussi nous ce qui nous concerne entendre
le collectif des parties civiles c'est
la lutte contre les personnes
soupçonnées d'avoir participé au
génocide et guy sié qui vite en france
et là nous avons encore de nombreux
dossiers que la justice n'a pas n'a
toujours pas clôturé et donc nous nous
attendons de nombreux procès dans les
mois voire dans les années à venir et je
rappelle que malheureusement pour d'art
tout le retard qui a été pendant ses
nombreuses années ne se rattrapera
jamais mais là pour le coup ya
effectivement des enquêtes en cours
encore aujourd'hui
oui les juges d'instruction continuent
de se déplacer au mans dans nos
commissions rogatoires tous les amants
une des juges a convoqué ici toutes les
parties pour une reconstitution de fait
dans un dossier le dossier du hêtre
marcel italienne joue
dès le mois prochain normalement aux
moines mais à partir du 2 mai se tiendra
à 6 de paris le procès d'un ancien
préfet du congo et au rwanda laurent
bucyibaruta un préfet procès il va durer
jusqu'au 1er juillet donc effectivement
la justice la justice avance la justice
avance doucement beaucoup trop doucement
point de vue mais on s'ouvre à on suivra
tout ça de très près merci alain gautier
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce matin
je le rappelle vous êtes co fondateur du
collectif des parties civiles pour le
rwanda